hey what's up my name's samuel elise i'm
here at the never use your own money
again program and i'm here with renato
renato and anna anna and what's just
happened guys
we just found the potential uh rent to
rent deal in milton keynes a potential
rent to rent deal in milton keynes what
is it what kind of property is it so
it's four different flats three one bed
one two bed and uh it's in the same
build building basically and she's happy
to do it we've told her everything up
front we have we were honest with her we
said it's a corporate letter she's happy
to do it so on monday we've booked to
the full feelings so you're going to
rent it and then you're going to put it
on airbnb on booking.com but you need to
meet her you need to see the property
now we're at the new germany again and
because they've done so well we've
actually agreed for them to go down in
milton keynes with ricky
why did you agree to go with them you
know they found a deal they're taking
action and you know i remember when i
went to my first never use your money
again program i was like man i've got
these deals i just want some support so
their energy the way that they carry
themselves and there's another reason
what was the other reason
oh because uh we've done a little task
to see who who's got the most viewings
and you bought the most views and we
just put the most
seven viewings and i'm like man you
booked so many viewings you made one big
move now we're gonna make a big move so
ricky's gonna go out to the property are
you expecting good things i'm expecting
massive things so let's see what happens
if you want to see what happens keep
watching don't forget to like the video
subscribe i'm looking forward to finding
out what happens tomorrow baby
we're here with anna and renato they're
just pulling up they booked viewings we
were an advanced training program and
they booked the most viewings so we said
we'll come and do the viewings with you
they're just pulling up let's go and
speak to him find out what's going on
hey
coming oh how are you guys doing
brilliant how are you i'm good i'm
excited how are you feeling
so let's talk what's what's this we've
got these viewings how many viewers have
we got four four viewers yes four flats
and what's the plan
plan is to get them done
get them negotiating get it done and
what are you looking to use them for
service accommodation service
accommodation yep yep okay are you
feeling confident yeah 100 come on let's
do it is it is the landlord open to it
yeah yeah we've told everything before
on the call because the last thing we
want is to come here and she's
completely blind of artists yeah she's
agreed and we're here because you were
at the advanced training you're booking
the most viewings we're like we're going
to come with you and help you out yeah
you ready for coming yeah yeah you're
welcome we get it done let's go let's go
let's go let's make it happen
[Music]
yeah
you're not the go-to man
so do you wash your are you the manager
of the building are you so who
is it like an in-house manager who
manages all of the lens
so this is one bed
and do you know do you know the landlord
personally beer yeah what's their what
are they asking for this one sorry i
think these are 900
950. okay cool anything you are
interested in obviously note down and
then talk to lingard yeah
okay cool right
perfect yeah it's really nice inside
they're like they're almost like they're
like luxury apartments
and i'm assuming obviously it comes as
it comes as it is
yeah what's the um i'm not from this
kind of
i've got apartments
in the center in the center right so
this part of will kings what is the
businesses next door is there a lot of
business around here right so when you
say the only you mean the freeholder of
the whole thing yeah right
cool
so okay has he got other buildings
around memphians then yeah
it's cool
yeah
all right this is nice
[Laughter]
that's a good one so there's that so we
think that's 900 or something a month
so with regards to like
the the rent and stuff like that is
something that we would have to speak to
the landlord about what what is this
how occupied is this place at the minute
are there any any other how many empty
ones are there in total
[Music]
and are they all
is it a majority of them asc contracts
or
there are a couple of million fees the
good thing is because we do because
obviously there's going to be a company
there we do this we've got experience in
it and what we do is we put limitations
in there to stop parties because
obviously it's in our best interest we
don't know parties
right so we have like noise limiters we
have uh
mainly noise numbers where we have
certain decibel ping our phone and then
yeah and then we can we've got like our
own team that can come in and find
what's going on or if we decided we want
to take one of these on um then we could
obviously contact you guys if you're
already here anyway but we make sure we
limit the the parties and stuff like
that
are the businesses around here in this
state are they big businesses that they
get a lot of like employees and
directors and stuff coming over
do you know the majority of what their
clients are coming in to stay for the
for the short stays i'm wondering
if if it's possible if it's not going to
be too much of a hassle because this
one's quite nice
for
us to to refer back to
are we able just to get like a video
walkthrough of this is that all right
see if you've got your phone
[Music]
so
[Music]
do you need a fob to get into the front
door
what we're looking to do the rent
deposits stuff like that that all will
have to go through the landlord is it
can you able to help us with anything
you know well what we'll do we'll
probably do how many more to look at um
quite a few
all the others in one bit anyway
so if we look if we look at are they
very similar to this
well to the other one to the other yeah
but that's probably the smallest one
okay i thought i would get the worst one
yeah yeah get don't get the worst one
out of the way
all right if we look at one more yeah um
because it's
it's not they're all very
very good condition
we'll look at one more and then um we'll
because i know someone wouldn't be
downstairs yeah we'll look at one more
and then we'll probably we can ring the
landlord and and discuss with them yeah
perfect
right so we need to ring the landlord
oh you've got a number gone
all right let's train the landlord so
this is what you're gonna say
um you just say hey we'll just feed the
property um i'm with my business partner
ricky i'm gonna hand you over to him now
just have a chat okay
hello hello elena
this is renato i just viewed the flats
yeah i'm here with my business partner
is it okay to have a quick chat with him
his name is ricky
uh sure
hi there elena it's ricky spearkin how
are you
hi ricky good good how are you doing
yeah i'm very well thank you thanks for
allowing us to view the properties and
have a look around they look very very
nice they're very very luxury aren't
they
oh well we're trying our best yeah no
very nice so um
yeah we met a guy called jamie who
showed us around really really helpful
yes he is yeah so making me know as well
yeah no he's doing a really good job so
um it was just with regards to the
apartment so we looked at three out of
the four we didn't look at the fourth
one because we thought
they're all very very high condition we
really really like them so
um
roughly more or less the same i mean
just the shapes a little bit different
yeah yeah no they're all very it's
exactly what we're looking for so i just
wanted to kind of talk to you about you
know what we're looking to do in the and
the numbers side of things and see if we
can we can come to an agreement and and
take them on
so
if we start off with um we viewed a
one-bedroom flat and if we start with
the what the one bedroom one what was
the rent you were asking for for the one
bedroom one
uh sorry are you for the corporate lab
or is it for the private lab this is for
a company lab
we
can we can do we can do six months
contract uh with options to extend for
another for another six and the
condition that you pay six months in
advance so if you you already paid six
months in advance on the fifth month you
would pay another six months in advance
yeah but that if if there was
maintenance issues that cost would come
out of your pocket right
um yeah so if it came out of our pocket
and we took care of the maintenance
would it be fair to say that we could we
could reduce the rent a little bit
considering we were going to take care
of the maintenance for you
um
it depends what you're going to specify
as a maintenance of what you're going to
be taking care of sure i understand so
if we could agree obviously we'd have to
we'd have to um kind of have a think
about it and really get something done
of course in writing but i'm thinking
what i usually do is we'll take care of
all of the maintenance up to 150 pounds
so anything over the first over the
course of the term that's 150 pounds up
to 150 pounds will take care of the
price um and then anything over 150
pounds like white goods
not so much here but
you want us to cover no the first time
first 150 we will cover for maintenance
so any any any any maintenance that
needs doing 450 pounds or less we will
cover in our terms and then anything
over 150 like white goods stuff like
that then that would be your
responsibility over 150 pounds so
you know that would save you a bit of
money there on the maintenance so
there's four available
on the basis that we send you over
company details and on the basis
oh please
you can hear me okay
sorry that's okay well i'm just saying
i'll i'll i'll let you
i'll let you go go in a second i was
just saying there's four available on
the basis of you know the rent and we
can agree the terms with like the
maintenance and and the long term let um
and of course we'll send you over all of
our company details and you can check us
out and stuff like that on all of that
on that basis if everyone's happy would
you be happy to proceed if we took on
the four apartments
um yes sure
okay perfect still available yes right
but it has to be only one goal it's not
like one now and two more later another
one later
yeah not work that's great well look it
was great speaking with you what i'll do
is i'll get renato my business partner
to send you over all the details you
need um and then we'll we'll send you
over where we stand um you know with
regards to like terms and stuff like
that and then we'll come to an agreement
and make sure both sides are happy if
both sides are happy then great we'll
proceed if not you know it's no problem
um but we'll send you over everything
we've got and where we stand
all right um i will text you my email
address
perfect thank you so much for your time
um mentioned please the flats that
you're interested in yeah we'll put
we'll put the the we'll put the ones
that we're interested in i'm gonna take
the one you're gonna take the one the
only thing i don't like is those five
months yeah
right now the difficult thing is
obviously she's got she's got an idea of
what she wants you know with the terms
and stuff like that which is fine it's
hard to
um you know
change it's hard to negotiate terms like
that over the phone because we've tried
it and then she's she's trying to change
things so what i'm thinking the best
thing to do is she said
with what we've based on what we said
with the rents the maintenance and
everything like that based on what she's
she's all in she's happy to go for it so
what we need to do now is you need to
send her over what she wants the company
details stuff like that also i would
send her over where you stand you know
look this because i explained to you on
the phone look if we took care of the
maintenance would it be fair that we've
got money off the rent so i would put
that on the email and say look if we
took care of the materials like we said
up to 150 pounds considering we're doing
this considering this considering this
would you agree to 995 pounds a month
you know and if she's happy and you're
going to take on multiple ones she's
happy with that great if not then you
just have to renegotiate and if it
doesn't work it doesn't work but you've
got someone that's open to it now
they're ready like they're in they just
need your details okay so now you also
need to make sure it's going to work
make sure it's going to stack do more of
the due diligence and make sure you're
happy before you take it on but i think
it's been pretty successful i think it
was as well 100 what are you thinking
positive yeah i'm positive how are you
feeling now feeling good feeling good
feeling good learning from the vest
learning from the best see you come on
you come on the training so can you see
everything we've done on the train and
we did this yes and now we're here doing
it do you think after doing the training
you're going to be comfortable doing
this yourself yeah 100 percent 100 i
think if it wasn't with the training i
don't think i would have yeah it gives
me confidence it teaches me what i
didn't know so yeah hundred percent
yeah should we ring samuel let's do it
should we have a touring tamil
let's see what's gonna be like tell me
let's see let's see what samuel says
hey what's happening brother
good man you good yeah right right now
i'm with anna hi i'm renato
how are you
awesome thanks good do you want to
awesome too we've just come out of this
apartment block and we've just done four
viewings yeah tell sammy what's happened
go on
well we viewed this flat
um these four flats were amazing very
luxury
very high
uh we're happy to proceed
she's happy to go on board ricky
negotiated it all he's done
all the work
um but she's happy to proceed now she
just needs our details over an email and
then then she'll make a decision
basically
so
so we rang with the viewing was actually
with the management company and we rang
the landlord after and the landlord
wanted to negotiate some some of the
terms like the length of term and the
rent um but that she's agreed on
principal we send over company details
she's in
oh amazing yeah so you guys could have
four luxury apartments in the next
couple weeks that looks so good
very high standard it could come
furnished as well he's i mean they're
very they're very nice and we were just
saying we were just saying what what we
did in there is exactly what you guys
did on the training 100
100 do you think you can do on your own
now that you've been through the
training do you think you can do it oh
yeah 100 with more practice we'll get
there
i feel more confident as well thanks to
the training otherwise i would have been
able to do it
yes of course
the experience is the skills that we're
getting so that's so it's all win-win if
you happen to the first viewing well
brilliant
yeah keep going so you guys come to the
training this week yes so what's the
biggest what's the biggest takeaway from
the training from what's the biggest
takeaway from everything it's just the
confidence and
the vibe you guys give
you're amazing trainers just amazing
trainers and we trust you so much that's
why we went to the academy yeah because
we believe and we see results
yeah i mean i i never called any agent
before i used to do my due diligence and
i'll pass it on yeah you do the call but
then when we went to the training now
you have to
and i thought that's when i was like
okay let me just call let me just call
i've got i've got the script i've got
everything with me let me just call and
i did and that's when we booked so many
viewings and i was like i can do this
if you have to give one piece of advice
to anyone watching this oh sign up
just go go to the crash course go to
your crash course see how it is you'll
get hooked straight away it's just these
guys are brilliant they're the best in
the game
[Music]